Before we wrap up this lesson, let's hear from Eytan and Sean, who are also
two data scientists at Facebook. They'll offer
their advice for how to work with data.
>> My advice to data scientists, or future data
scientists is find data sets that you're interested in,
and, and work with them, and play with the
data. And just developed experience with playing with data.
>> Good data science comes from good
questions, not from fancy techniques, or from, you know, having the right
data. It comes from motivating your research with an idea that you care
about, and that you think other people will care about. It's almost, you
almost have to think about it like a journalist would. You have this
audience and they're going to consume the work that you produce, and you
want them to care about it, and be interested. And so, starting with
the right questions, in, in particular, something that motivates you as a person
is really the right starting point, not, like, you know, some fancy technique
that you want to learn.